so we're on three we just went through
security to get to the western wall
which will be upon our right in the
moment well I just kind of thought I
didn't really think so many people would
be here now because security is so tent
sonoda at the Wailing Wall because
people come here and cry and pour their
hearts out to the wall because I think
people feel closer to God here and she's
around the world when we pray we faced
Jerusalem we face here so in America
that means East but here into whatever
direction and the wall is closest I
would say the holiest site for Jews is
the Temple Mount but we don't have we
don't have like we don't have any
structure there that's remaining from
the temple and so the whole yet the
holiest remaining thing that's standing
for cheese I would say is this over here
but the holiest site is is up on the
Temple Mount which is why it's so
contentious
you know I think it really in an ideal
world like me everybody everybody in the
world could have freedom to one of the
places that were most meaningful to them
given the really harsh realities here
that's not the case it's difficult I
think we're all sort of like learning
how to navigate that and some some in
more painful ways than others
Jerusalem police and Muslims Christians
and Jews this by those idea police when
just to us